foreign
it's a long despairing walk back to town
they've tried and failed to make it
across to Europe
foreign
this man from Ivory Coast calls
tunisia's National Guard robbers and
racists he says they took their
belongings and left them stranded on the
water
you got it they took the engines of five
boats he says stopping them from getting
to Italy and leaving them to row back to
shore with their hands
estate endorsed Crackdown has seen black
migrants chased out of their homes and
now blocked by the Coast Guard as they
try to leave
we want to know why asks mama do they
said we have to leave the country and
then don't let us go anywhere
ancient Market has become a meeting
point for migrants figuring out their
next move unable to turn back to the
conflict and instability they originally
fled
Mustafa has made three separate attempts
to cross into Europe by boat he's paid a
thousand dollars every single time
he told us they were eight meters from
Italian Waters when the National Guard
sent them back now he waits saving up
money for his next attempt
in the still hours of the night
arrangements for departure begin
we spoke to a trafficker who helps
migrants get to the beaches they leave
from
thousands of people are leaving
but there are many catastrophes he says
he counts 130 dead some of them his
clients he says more than a hundred have
been saved
not by the Coast Guard
but by the fisherman
this man has been on the water since he
had seven years old just a boy and said
he's never seen anything like this
before hundreds of migrants leaving to
Italy Every Morning by boat and many of
them drowning
we wake up in the morning to check our
fishing nets and find dead bodies
this is a crisis
the Italian Coast Guard has said it
rescued around 750 migrants in two
operations of the Southern Italian Coast
[Music]
hundreds are still missing
ibrahim's been told that his brother's
boat has sunken on its way to Italy
but despite his brother drowning he'll
cross when he has the chance
we are born from the same mother he says
but we don't have the same luck I can
cross and make it
for young men and women like Ibrahim
these water signal opportunity the
ultimate gamble for a better life that's
getting riskier by the day
Tunisia